-we're talking to the one,
the only Whoopi Goldberg!
We love you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every time you come on,
I love you,
but we always have
to talk about something.
So you do these holiday
collections.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-It's not just sweaters,
but it's also socks.
-Yeah.
-And you have --
-Mittens.
-Last year was masks.
-Yes.
-And you did scarves.
And they're just fun.
Like, let's just look at them.
-And they're, you know...
This one's neat.
This one's there's
all different ways
to say happy hol--
Yeah, no, look at that.
It got awws.
That one's got aww.
-Aww.
-Yeah! that's what you want
with a sweater.
-Yeah.
-And they're fun.
And they're funny
and they're cool.
Look at this one.
-And they're really good.
-"Merry freaking Christmas."
That's -- check it out.
[ Laughter ]
That's what I'm talking about.
-Yeah.
-But this is a very special
process for all of these.
And can you explain to me
how does this get made?
-Well, they say, "Okay, we need
to know what you want to do."
-Uh-huh.
-And I go "okay."
[ Light laughter ]
And then I do whatever
I need to do,
and then I take a pen.
-Uh-huh.
-And I -- I draw on them.
-You draw them like --
-And then I say,
"Here they are."
[ Laughter ]
-But look at this.
You sent us one of the drawings.
-Yes.
-This is it.
-That's -- that's my --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
That's the expensive one.
-"I'm so broke,"
and here's a broken gingerbread.
-Yes.
-And then,
they turn it into this,
And says, "I'm so broke."
"I'm sooo broke."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, snap."
I love it.
-And they're silly,
and they're meant
to make you laugh
and they're meant to make you
go, "Oh, come on, really?"
[ Laughter ]
You know, they are.
-But that's what they're for,
and they're happy
and they're good.
-Yeah. yeah.
-And well,
I'm just going to say --
-And they're from kids.
I think we have some
kids stuff also.
-You have kids stuff too?
-And mittens and socks
and stuff.
-I was gonna say, it's fun
and it's -- it's loud
and it's cozy.
-Yes.
-And it's you.
-It is me.
Can I show this one?
-Yeah, that's the one.
-This one, I --
-That's -- that's the headliner.
-So I wanted --
-That's the closer.
-Wanted to make it so that you
could jump up and down.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Like A --
-Jimmy: Shake it.
Shake a snow globe.
-Shake it up, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And they --
and they said,
"No, you can't do that."
-Yeah, yeah.
So we got it, so, you know,
it's...
-It's close enough.
-...got some stuff in it.
Put it, and you know what?
Do a handstand.
-Yeah.
-Why not? Exactly.
-It's just -- you know, look.
It's been a rough
couple of years.
-Yeah, exactly right.
Make someone laugh.
Come on, why not?
-Yeah, make yourself laugh.
-Yeah.
-You know, just give it
as a present and say, "Hey."
-Yeah.
-You've been very dour.
Put this on."
-Yeah.
-You know?
-We love it when you come by,
and thank you for always coming
by and bringing the goodies
and bringing the love
and the funny.
There's no one like you.
You're the greatest.
Whoopi Goldberg!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The 2021 holiday collection
is available now at
nordstrom.com and berek.com.